delivering some breaking news now and a
team searching for the missing plane
carrying cardiff city footballer
Emiliano Salah and his pilot David I
Batson
say that they've located the light
aircraft the search area was reduced to
just four square miles north of Guernsey
and two vessels were looking for any
trace of that light aircraft after
enough money was raised in an online
appeal to fund the venture well let's
get the very latest on that development
now our correspondent on Parmenter is in
Guernsey for us now so Tom what are you
hearing well a navi vessel that had been
involved in the search the smaller
privately funded vessel made its way
back to Guernsey this evening
unexpectedly and David means the
shipwreck hunter who has led that side
of the search has just stepped off the
jetty here in Guernsey and has told us
that yes he has today
identified and confirmed the wreckage
and location of that aircraft that of
course has been missing for 13 days now
since emiliano solidly cardiff city
footballer who had just signed for the
club was flying over the English Channel
with pilot David Ibbotson they
disappeared off the radar and it was
early this morning about 9:00 a.m. in
the very early stages of the search that
had got underway at first light this
morning out in this zone 24 miles north
of Guernsey that they saw something with
the sonar equipment that they had on
board they carried out further passes
over that area to pinpoint and have a
closer look they went through various
stages of identification through the
course of today and David me ins the man
leading that private searchers as I said
just confirm to me that they have now
positively identified the wreckage as
that of the plane that had been carrying
the Argentinian footballer importantly
both sets of families have been earlier
today informed of that development
devastating news is how David Mills
described it to me they didn't want to
go into any further details but they
said that at least they have been able
to bring some kind of answer to the
family as to where that plane ended up
very very
sad news indeed and David min said all
the way back here to Guernsey his
thoughts were with the families that of
course have been waiting for some kind
of clarification as to what happened to
their loved ones after that ill-fated
flight across the English Channel and of
course Emiliano
Salah remembered just last night at the
first home game that Cardiff City had
against Bournemouth a victory where he
was very much and the pilot very much in
the thoughts of everyone at Cardiff City
Football Club FC nantes as well the club
that he had been playing for had been
holding vigils over the course of the
last couple of weeks
very very distressing news but the
confirmation coming through in the last
10 minutes or so to us direct from David
mins as he stepped off the jetty here in
Guernsey they have located the plane the
process now is that the Air Accident
Investigation Board vessel which is out
there still in the search zone that will
stay in position they will go through
the formalities the paperwork necessary
in the recovery process of that wreckage
it's likely to take some time but for
the private search that of course had
been crowdfunded by so many donations
they have now concluded their work
they've docked back here in Guernsey and
they have done their job but that of
course is to deliver the devastating
news to the families involved who have
been waiting for 13 days to find out
what had happened to their loved ones